on how to do a phd so mainly that you
don't repeat my mistakes
um train
[Music]
they've made it into a phd program
congratulations
you made it so today we're going to have
a look at
what to do during a phd how to succeed
at publishing papers
how to deal with reviews what to do at
conferences and
many other things so i hope you enjoy
this little
guide of how to survive a machine
learning phd
in 2021
so first of all let me say i'm not good
at this
i'm not an expert i'm at the end of my
phd and i've done
many things wrong and by no means am i a
successful academic
however if you're like myself and at the
beginning of your phd
you don't really have a clue what to do
you don't know how to select topics you
don't know how to write papers or even
what a paper is really
then there might be something in here
that could help you i'm not
super successful myself but what i can
tell you is that i've seen many people
who are good at it
so i can tell you what those people did
right
what i did wrong and generally what i
think you should do all right that being
said
let's dive right in when it comes down
to choosing a topic
make sure you look for something that
your advisor
or the senior people around you have
lots of experience in they can help you
much better like this
you also want to choose something that
matches your particular interests
because you're going to be stuck with it
for a while lastly
you want to choose something that fits
your expertise where you're
already reasonably good at or can get
good at very quickly
at the intersection of those three
things you're gonna find something
that is unique to you and is going to be
a very good topic for your phd
but there are a few more things to
consider when selecting a topic
first of all resources how much access
to resources you have
will determine what kind of topics are
even accessible to you
as a researcher so i'm going to assume
that you do not have a
giant compute cluster or heaps of money
around
and therefore my recommendations are
going to be for
let's say the rather average phd student
who
is not a giant tech company however if
you do
happen to have thousands of tpus in your
backyard
ignore my advice and just train big
language models
alright there are two fundamental ways
how you can choose a topic
way one is to choose the biggest most
hyped topic
in the area right now now that is not
necessarily a bad strategy but it has
some drawbacks
and the reason is that in a hype topic
there are many papers but there is also
a giant amount of competition not only
from other researchers but from
large corporations with lots and lots of
resources behind them
and the bigger reason why it's a bad
idea is the fact that they
wane if you pick transformers to
research today
it's very likely that three four years
down the road
you'll still be stuck with transformers
the field has moved on
and now all of these people that have
made the same choice
namely to invest in the biggest topic
right now
are trying to finish their phd are
trying to get
papers published in that topic that is
no longer
of such a big interest at that
particular point in time and therefore
already be
on the declining side of the hype cycle
so what's the alternative to hype topics
the alternative is
niche topics and that's what i would
recommend for most people
the advantages of finding niches is
there isn't as much competition around
and you can actually become an expert
and the best at whatever you do
some examples of niche topics are things
like
bandits optimization biologically
plausible neural network
text-based games i'm not suggesting you
go into these topics
but look for smaller communities that
nevertheless
publish year after year after year
alright so
now the important stuff how do you get
papers published
now if i had to summarize the style
of writing papers that get published in
one sentence is that write papers that
cannot be rejected and that is not as
obvious as it sounds
the review process in machine learning
is heavily incentivized
to reject your paper as quickly and
easily as possible
do not give reviewers any reason to
reject
your paper and the easiest way to learn
how to write
papers is to literally read papers
go into your niche gather the papers
that are there
read them try to emulate their writing
style
try to emulate the type and way they do
and present experiments try to emulate
the way they
write up theoretical foundations for
their ideas
your goal is going to be to write a
paper where there is no
obvious criticism to be had by reviewers
reviews are the single biggest obstacle
to achieving your goals
and let me tell you right now getting
reviews is
one of the most cruel experiences you're
going to have
in your phd reviewers are nasty
they don't have time they don't read the
paper correctly they misunderstand
they criticize that you didn't evaluate
on some obscure data set and in general
you're going to feel quite misunderstood
by reviewers
this happens to all of us what i can
tell you is
don't get discouraged by bad reviews
don't take individual reviews
too seriously and just resubmit the
paper to the next
conference so keep your sanity don't
take it personally there are many
famous papers that have been rejected at
first try
and not because the paper was bad but
just because the reviewers
were crappy now there are going to be
things during your phd that you'll have
to do
that are not writing papers and one of
those things
is especially as you get more senior
you're going to be asked to review
yourself now it is an easy option to
take
all that frustration that you have
against reviewing
and you see all these other people doing
such a crappy job
that you just think whatever i'm going
to do a crappy job myself and it's
tempting
it's very tempting especially because
you gain
nothing from doing good reviews but
other than uh
you hey thanks for the review you'll get
nothing
and it is really really hard to write a
good review
do it nevertheless please not only are
you helping the field
by being not one of the crappy reviewers
but writing a good review
also helps you really dig into a paper
really see the weaknesses in other
papers
and it makes you a better author
researcher and community member so for
your own sake and for the community
take the review seriously even though
you don't have time
even though other people do a crappy job
another thing that you're going to be
asked to do very probably
is teaching now again you're going to
have very little incentive to do a good
job at teaching
after all students are nuisances the
faster you can get it over with the
better the earlier you can go back to
writing papers however i urge you to
take
teaching seriously not only because the
world
relies on the next generation of
researchers being competent
but also think about the fact that the
people you teach will be
probably some of them working with you
in the future they might be
researchers in other labs you
collaborate with they might even be
joining
your own lab and you will profit from
them being more competent so
take teaching seriously for your benefit
and for the benefit of your students
so besides the things you have to do
like reviewing and teaching
what should you work on all day and
here's my answer
start working on your thing go pee
and then continue working on your thing
a phd
is first and foremost an exercise in
long-term
focus you're going to be tempted to do
all kinds of things
during your phd you're going to look and
here's a reading group and here's a
seminar and here's a lecture
now unless it is on your specific thing
on your specific niche
it's probably going to be not a
productive use of your time
i'm not saying you shouldn't go there
what i'm saying is that
be aware that what ultimately gets you
to get your papers
is a long-term laser focus
on your topic and other topics will
creep
up on you it's going to be so
interesting because you're stuck here
with your thing that you know and that
is boring
and there's going to be this other cool
topic wow
here we are this is the nurip's 2019
poster session
one of the poster sessions there are
about 250 posters in this room
and there are so many people it is
crazy every single poster has a like a
ball of people around a presenters
trying to explain
to the bystanders their work
they're visibly and you're going to be
tempted oh this is interesting this is
interesting this is interesting
and my topic is so lame i'm going to
just look into this
and that's all so cool yeah
you know that me
it did not turn out well focus focus
focus focus your research on
your thing and you'll be successful
so now you've written your paper you've
submitted it to peer review and with a
little bit of luck
you've actually managed to get it
published and you get to go
to a conference now the conference
itself
and the conference website and everyone
on twitter
might give you the impression that
conferences are there
for people giving talks about their
research and you
listening and learning that's crap
conferences
especially the talking part of
conferences have become
more and more irrelevant with the years
specifically now that everything is
recorded and streamed
just look at that stuff from the comfort
of your couch at 2x speed you're missing
nothing these talks are often very short
very rehearsed
and most importantly they are about
research that is at least
six months old the interesting part
about conferences
are the people there the interesting
talking happens in
workshops in panels in tutorials
try to find places where current
research
is discussed workshops are a great place
to go for this because the research is
often much more recent
and not done yet go to conferences
to interact with people this whole oh we
come together for research
that's a charade the best researchers i
know
do nothing else but meet and talk to
people
all day at conferences and i don't mean
this in a mean way i don't mean
go out and deliberately engineer contact
with people
for your own benefit no a conference is
a place
where you can find other people that are
interested in the same things
as you are and you can talk to them get
to know things that you could never get
to know
through a writing or in a paper a lot of
paper authors will tell you things
face to face that they would never write
down in a paper
such as which experiments that don't
work problems in research
weaknesses of papers you'll get a lot of
knowledge by
being there and talking to people but
you
have to go out of your way and do it
actively
i know this is hard for a lot of us but
it pays off
and it's going to make your life a lot
more enjoyable all right the next thing
i want to talk about is
internships should you go to an
internship at a company
at a different university and this
depends entirely on
your preference now i myself have had
pretty good experiences with internships
and
people i know have done so as well
generally
if you do an internship it gives you a
bit of a different perspective because
you do it
at a different place and if you do an
internship with a large company
it can be quite a switch of environment
you'll have access to
many more resources and you can do maybe
a little bit of a different type of
research and most importantly
you'll meet people that are not
academics or not academics anymore
and that is very very valuable
once you've been stuck in academia for a
while meeting someone
who just cares to build a cool product
is
so refreshing and gets you a bit down to
earth with
what's really important lastly i want to
talk about the topic of collaborations
now academia is a bit tricky in that the
system
tries to alienate and isolate you as a
person
you need those first author papers you
need to provide
a personal contribution to the knowledge
of humankind
look for people who have the same
interests in terms of topic
but who have a little bit different
skills or experiences
such that your papers and your research
can become more well-rounded
that could be a difference in
theoretical versus experimental
knowledge
that could be a difference in your
academic background so if you
can find someone that has complementary
skills to yours
and is interested in the same niche it
definitely pays off
to work together and produce research
together however
only do this if they really work in the
same
field it is very tempting to start all
kinds of collaborations with people
all over the place if you can handle
that good for you
but again it pays to have a little bit
of focus
on your particular field and really view
collaborations as a joint effort to get
research done more quickly and
with more rigor right so the way i
discussed it right now
it seems like doing a phd is gruelsome
and lots of work and you never get to do
anything fun
and while there is an aspect to that and
it definitely can happen
to people especially if they want to
finish real quickly
i urge you to also make some time to
enjoy this time a phd is a cool time
you'll get to meet so many interesting
people get to learn so many interesting
topics and ideas and you'll hopefully
get to
go to many interesting places and
that is an invaluable experience so my
advice
is if you can take it a bit easier
enjoy your time take as much out of it
as you can and don't work all the time
maybe you'll have half a year longer who
cares
you only get to do a phd once and enjoy
the time at university while you still
can you can get a job any day so i hope
you've gained
at least something from this video and
you should be on a path to a successful
machine learning
phd cheers
you